So my husband and I are taking our big kids out to dinner tonight
and then onto a haunted carriage ride here in Charleston.
It's one of these things we've always wanted to do,
but we just have never done.
And since it's the week of Halloween,
it is the perfect time to go do a haunted Charleston carriage ride.
So I'm putting my outfit together.
This is where we are so far.
I kind of love how the stripe of the shoe
matches the black and white stripe of the top.
It's giving very, like,
Addams Family.
I love. So for accessories,
I'm kind of between a couple pieces.
For the headband, I have this sparkly black one.
This one that's, like,
a cheap one off of Amazon with, like,
a little couple pearls on it.
And then this, my orange one from Brianna Cannon,
which I think would be fun to add in the halloweeny colors,
add that little pop of orange.
My kids are also wearing orange,
so I think I might go with this one.
But let's see.
The black and white could be cute, too.
I kind of like the orange.
Try this one.
That's very, like,
subtle and demure, which I don't think is what we're going for,
especially because these are the earrings.
They're little spider webs.
Okay. I went with the orange because I think it's just.
It's Halloween. We're leaning into it.
And this is the outfit. Added a little belt.
Right here. And I'm so excited.
I can't wait to go. I think we're gonna have so much fun.
I love Halloween.